[Musique]
les acteurs du sport se sont réunis ce
vendredi 29 avril dans l'hémicycle du
conseil départemental pour une
présentation du plan 5000 licence au
département alloue un budget de 500
mille euros pour le financement de
licences de loisir et de compétition
dans le fond il s'inscrit dans la
stratégie pauvreté qui est un dispositif
qui a été lancé par l'état depuis 2010 9
qui vise à lutter contre le torino et
territoires et donc dans ce cadre là
depuis plusieurs mois ont trahi le
département de mettre en oeuvre des
actions diverses donc le plan à 5000
licence s'inscrit dans la volonté de
faciliter l'accès au dessous des
familles des sportives et physiques le
plan 5 me sens comme le passeport
d'ailleurs puisque plusieurs objectifs
notamment
améliorer le bien être la santé des
jeunes également aider les familles
notamment celles qui ont plusieurs
enfants à pouvoir adhérer à des clubs et
pratique d'activités sportives et enfin
soutenir la relance du mouvement sportif
qui a été durement frappée par la crise
et une aide exceptionnelle accordée aux
foyers les plus modestes visant à
garantir l'accès de tous à la pratique
du sport dans le cadre du plan pauvreté
nous avons
réservé une somme de d'un demi million
d'euros pour financer les licences pour
les personnes les jeunes de moins de 21
ans qui sont en situation de pauvreté
dont les familles sont en situation de
pauvreté et qui sont bénéficiaires du
rsa donc l'objectif c'est faire en sorte
de l'accès au sport pour tous les
publics en particulier les publics qui
sont en situation de précarité
5600 euros donc prise en charge par le
département dans le cadre du plan
propreté procès public en grande
difficulté faire en sorte de rendre
accessible le sport de promouvoir
l'égalité des chances dans le cadre de
cette action en partenariat avec les
urgences de mettre en actes ce soutien
au sport de masse a été renforcée par la
crise sanitaire en 2020 le nombre de
licenciés a chuté de 70% chez les plus
jeunes à toutes les nations sont
partie prenante puisque c'est un vol tn
un bol d'oxygène pour l'ensemble de nos
clubs si ces cinq cent mille euros c'est
un demi million qu on réinjecte dans
l'économie locale et qui vont transiter
par nos clubs et associations et c'est
un soulagement bien sûr pour les
familles en définitive mais c'est aussi
des liens de gros enjeux au delà de la
pauvreté d'économie de te relancer ce
que je sais de plaisir de bien-être de
santé puis pour bienfaits du sport aussi
pour ça l'aide du plan 5800 correspond à
un montant maximum de 100 euros par
jeune l'aide versée directement au club
elle n'est mobilisables qu'une seule
fois par saison sportive et par
bénéficiaire dans une seule discipline
[Musique]